president erdogan started the
celebrations early last night he is
close to winning but he's not there yet
the election campaign will finish with a
runoff but erdogan will be the clear
favorite after taking nearly half the
popular vote
he said we strongly believe that we will
continue to serve our nation for the
next five years
the runoff will be against Kamal
kalistarolo who released a short video
his supporters were all in his heart and
that he would fight to the end
but this could be the kingmaker the
nationalists in on Iran who got more
than five percent in the election that's
nearly 3 million votes
he told me he will endorse someone but
he expects a ministerial job in return
because
this has been a bruising and divisive
campaign and it's got another Fortnight
to run
this election has uncovered some
profound scars in Turkish Society
differences based on yes politics but
also culture social background religion
and of course geography whoever wins and
it will probably be president erdogan is
going to have to decide whether they
unite this nation or simply rule it
certainly people are polarized in their
opinions about erdogan this election is
really a referendum on him
erdogan will do everything by Democratic
way you think he might cheat huh
I think
election observers say erdogan holds an
unfair Advantage but their criticism
won't really disturb him the second
round is already looming the president
one of the great survivors of global
politics is the favorite to win again
Adam Parsons Sky News anchor